Lucia: （歌词）summertime and the living's easy
Lucia: (Lyrics) Summertime and the living's easy
Lucia: （歌词）writings on the microphone with ros and g
Lucia: (Lyrics) Writings on the microphone with Ros and G
Lucia: （歌词）all the people in the dance agree
Lucia: (Lyrics) All the people in the dance agree
Lucia: （歌词）that we will qualify to represent the l b c
Lucia: (Lyrics) That we will qualify to represent the LBC
Lucia: （歌词） me and Louie
Lucia: (Lyrics) Me and Louie
Lucia: （歌词）we gonna run to the party and dance to the rhythm gets harder
Lucia: (Lyrics) We gonna run to the party and dance to the rhythm gets harder
Jake:哎杯子呢杯子呢
Jake: Hey, where's the cup, where's the cup?
Lucia: 扫完了吗
Lucia: Are you done cleaning?
Jake:二楼扫完了
Jake: The second floor is all swept.
Lucia: 啊好的
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Jake:你可以一直在外边
Jake: You can stay outside.
Lucia: 这里
Lucia: Here.
Alice:不喝桃子
Alice: No peach drink.
Alice:我想喝水
Alice: I want water.
Jake:刚拿了一个杯子
Jake: Just got a cup.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈你们就说渴了
Jake: Haha, you guys just said you were thirsty.
Lucia: 昨天有
Lucia: Yesterday, there was.
Alice:你以为跟你一样
Alice: You think like you.
Alice:一晚上猛涨
Alice: Grows rapidly overnight.
Alice:我想喝水
Alice: I want water.
Alice:没长手
Alice: Can't grow hands.
Lucia: 您扫的时候我的鱼有掉下来吗
Lucia: Did my fish fall when you were sweeping?
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Lucia: 啊那太好了
Lucia: Ah, that's great.
Jake:你扫的时候他可一点都没动
Jake: When you were sweeping, it didn't move at all.
Lucia: 如果它掉下来就会不好看
Lucia: If it fell, it wouldn't look good.
Jake:好看好看好看
Jake: Looks good, looks good, looks good.
Jake:喝点
Jake: Have a drink.
Lucia: 没掉就行
Lucia: As long as it didn't fall.
其他人：你好大的架子
Others: You have such a big attitude.
其他人：还要逼boss给你拿杯子我的天
Others: Even need the boss to get you a cup, my god.
Jake:请请你你也来你也来
Jake: Please, please, you come too, you come too.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:给忘了忘了要扫
Jake: Forgot, forgot to sweep.
Jake:呵呵呵呵卧槽
Jake: Hehehe, damn it.
Lucia: 忘了要扫一楼了
Lucia: Forgot to sweep the first floor.
Lucia: 啊什么
Lucia: Ah, what?
Alice:他不应该在楼上扫完了吗
Alice: Shouldn't he have finished sweeping upstairs?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm.
Alice:然后他要扫楼下了
Alice: And then he has to sweep downstairs.
Alice:然后但是他坐这跟我们喝桃汁
Alice: But he's sitting here drinking peach juice with us.
Alice:我想着他是不是另有安排
Alice: I thought he had other plans.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Alice:然后呢哈哈
Alice: And then, haha.
Alice:一问他忘了
Alice: Asked him and he forgot.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我们的leader是一个
Lucia: Our leader is a...
Lucia: 非常随和的人
Lucia: Very easygoing person.
其他人：性情中人
Others: Emotional person.
Lucia: 对对对性情中人
Lucia: Yes, yes, very emotional.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
其他人：工作走到哪做到哪对对对
Others: Works everywhere they go, right, right.
Jake:喝这个桃汁他误事你知道吗
Lucia: 哈哈你这还没喝酒呢就开始误事了
Lucia: Haha, you haven't even had alcohol yet and you're already causing problems.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:桃汁
Jake: Peach juice.
Lucia: 啊他拿了四个杯子
Lucia: Ah, he took four cups.
Lucia: 那我也喝一个吧
Lucia: Then I'll have one too.
Lucia: 谢谢老板
Lucia: Thanks, boss.
其他人：这个还没用过
Others: This one hasn't been used yet.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 可先喝吗
Lucia: Can I drink first?
Lucia: 那我给老板倒点
Lucia: Then I'll pour some for the boss.
Lucia: 哎老板已经喝过了
Lucia: Oh, the boss already drank.
Lucia: 刚喝完就误事了
Lucia: Just drank and caused problems.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 给他倒点
Lucia: Pour him some.
Lucia: 等他回来喝
Lucia: Wait for him to come back and drink.
Lucia: 再无下一场不是哈哈
Lucia: No more next round, right? Haha.
Lucia: 哎这首歌好熟悉啊感觉听过
Lucia: Hey, this song sounds so familiar, feels like I've heard it before.
Alice:这么没有标志的声音
Alice: Such an unremarkable voice.
Lucia: 姐妹可以加你的微信吗
Lucia: Sis, can I add you on WeChat?
Lucia: 可以吗滚
Lucia: Can I? Go away.
Lucia: 哈哈哈今天加
Lucia: Hahaha, add today.
其他人：今天加
Others: Add today.
其他人：加也得加
Others: You have to add.
其他人：不加也得加
Others: You have to add even if you don't want to.
Lucia: 下班了
Lucia: Off work now.
Alice:我想加你的微信
Alice: I want to add you on WeChat.
Alice:小姐姐
Alice: Miss.
Lucia: 再加你你俩不熟吗
Lucia: Adding again, you two aren't close?
其他人：我就把你删掉好不好
Others: I'll just delete you, okay?
Alice:烦烦死你了
Alice: Annoying, you're so annoying.
Lucia: 原来你俩不熟啊
Lucia: So you two aren't close.
Alice:对不认识
Alice: Yeah, we don't know each other.
Lucia: 是是我唐突了
Lucia: Oh, I was being presumptuous.
Alice:不太认识他
Alice: I don't really know him.
其他人：不是你怎么叫我
Others: If you don't know him, why did you call me?
其他人：说你不认啊
Others: Saying you don't recognize him.
Lucia: 对是我
Lucia: Yes, it's me.
Lucia: 是是是这名
Lucia: Yes, yes, that's the name.
Lucia: 字有点抽象
Lucia: The characters are a bit abstract.
Lucia: 确实大家都这么说的哈哈
Lucia: Indeed, everyone says that, haha.
其他人：天呐备注
Others: Oh my, notes.
其他人：哈哈哈啊
Others: Hahaha.
Lucia: 不是不是
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 我会给你发名字的
Lucia: I'll send you the name.
其他人：OK OK
Others: OK, OK.
Lucia: 嗯对对
Lucia: Mm, right, right.
Alice:他叫Lucy啊
Alice: Her name is Lucia.
Lucia: 你这样录下来也行
Lucia: You can record it like this too.
Lucia: 哈哈也可以
Lucia: Haha, that's fine too.
Alice:罗马姐是吗
Alice: Is it Roma?
Lucia: 没事我哈哈
Lucia: No problem, haha.
Lucia: 罗马姐罗马分布
Lucia: Roma, Roma distribution.
Lucia: 罗马姐姐是可以的
Lucia: Roma sister is okay.
Lucia: 同学你叫什么名字
Lucia: Classmate, what's your name?
Lucia: 我叫姜露呀
Lucia: My name is Jiang Lu.
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
其他人：她念了一天了
Others: She's been saying it all day.
其他人：她在那我天天晚上听着
Others: I hear it every night.
其他人：长茧子了
Others: It's become a callus.
Lucia: 但是礼节性问一下
Lucia: 还是问一下
Lucia: Still need to ask.
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 推出一下
Lucia: Let's push it a bit.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈昌平分
Lucia: Hahaha, Changping distribution.
Lucia: 对我不
Lucia: Right, I don't.
Alice:昌平姐
Alice: Changping sister.
Lucia: 但我虽然我叫朱立文建材罗马分部
Lucia: Although my name is Zhu Liwen Jian Cai Roma Branch.
Lucia: 但我不叫朱立文
Lucia: But I'm not Zhu Liwen.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:这是昌平姐
Alice: This is Changping sister.
Alice:昌平别墅姐
Alice: Changping villa sister.
其他人：你名字太有迷惑性了
Others: Your name is too confusing.
Lucia: 是吧
Lucia: Right?
Lucia: 要的就是这个效果
Lucia: That's the effect I wanted.
Lucia: 没有让我来
Lucia: No, let me do it.
Alice:什么时候能去你家床上睡
Alice: When can I sleep in your bed?
其他人：想得美
Others: Dream on.
Lucia: 让我来认真的解释一下
Lucia: Let me explain seriously.
Lucia: 没有就是是为了
Lucia: No, it's because...
Lucia: 就是在国内点外卖的时候
Lucia: When ordering takeout in China,
Lucia: 看起来像男生
Lucia: it looks like a guy's name.
Lucia: 就是大概是那种AA建材猪哥的这种
Lucia: It's like those AA Construction Pig Brother names.
Lucia: 这种对
Lucia: Like that.
其他人：我懂了我淘宝也会换一个名字
Others: I get it, I change my name on Taobao too.
其他人：就比如说AA海鲜批发
Others: For example, AA Seafood Wholesale.
Alice:AA海鲜批发
Alice: AA Seafood Wholesale.
Lucia: 刘姐对对对
Lucia: Exactly, Liu Jie.
Alice:刘姐哈哈哈
Alice: Liu Jie, hahaha.
Lucia: 但是就是因为我很喜欢罗马这个城市
Lucia: But it's because I really like Rome.
Alice:烦我烦我
Alice: Annoying, annoying.
Alice:啥烦我啊
Alice: What do you mean annoying?
Lucia: 然后所以我就灵机一动
Lucia: So I got an idea.
Lucia: 把它写成了朱立文建材罗马分部
Lucia: I wrote it as Zhu Liwen Construction Rome Branch.
Lucia: 就你也可以叫我建材朱哥
Lucia: So you can call me Construction Pig Brother Zhu.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：地一样神认不出来呀哈哈哈
Others: It's hard to recognize, haha.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:啊哎呀哈哈哈你可
Alice: Ah, oh my, hahaha, you...
Lucia: 你你可以
Lucia: You, you can...
Lucia: 你可以给我备注AA建材朱哥
Lucia: You can note me as AA Construction Pig Brother Zhu.
Lucia: 这样你要找我
Lucia: So if you need to find me,
Lucia: 就是购买一些建材
Lucia: for buying construction materials,
Lucia: 或者施工的时候就比较方便找到我
Lucia: or for construction, it will be easier to find me.
Alice: 刘婷刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting, Liu Ting.
Lucia: 我开玩笑的
Lucia: Just kidding.
Lucia: 你随便备注
Lucia: You can note whatever you want.
Jake:我我第一次家里的时候
Jake: The first time at my house,
Jake:我以为你反向推销
Jake: I thought you were doing reverse marketing.
Jake:你知道反向推销
Jake: Do you know reverse marketing?
Lucia: 我吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Me? Hahaha.
Jake:投了个随便投了个简历
Jake: Just randomly submitted a resume.
Jake:然后让我去连续里买建材
Jake: And then let me go to the store to buy building materials.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哦
Lucia: Hahaha, oh.
Jake:毕竟我们也要租house啊
Jake: After all, we also need to rent a house.
Lucia: 其实也可以
Lucia: Actually, it's possible.
Lucia: 要不下次您考虑我一下
Lucia: How about considering me next time?
Jake:哎好嘞
Jake: Sure.
Alice:刘婷刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting, Liu Ting.
Lucia: 给我一个机会
Lucia: Give me a chance.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:你卖什么呀
Jake: What do you sell?
Lucia: 建材啊不是写的很清楚吗不是
Lucia: Building materials, isn't it clearly written?
Jake:建材多了
Jake: There are many types of building materials.
Jake:对哪哪种啊
Jake: Which kind?
Lucia: 呃只有只有只有你想不到
Lucia: Uh, only ones you can't think of.
Lucia: 没有我卖不了
Lucia: There's nothing I can't sell.
Jake:好的好的
Jake: Alright, alright.
Lucia: 这个这个
Lucia: This, this...
Lucia: 这个供货渠道啊
Lucia: This supply chain...
Lucia: 这个厂房啊都是非常的完备的
Lucia: The factory is very well-equipped.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 然后跟这些供货商
Lucia: And with these suppliers...
Lucia: 有很多年良好的合作关系
Lucia: We have many years of good cooperation.
Lucia: 就是这质量啊
Lucia: So the quality...
Lucia: 您大可放心啊
Lucia: You can rest assured.
Jake:好好好下回买
Jake: Alright, alright, next time I'll buy.
Lucia: 您大可胡说八道这货
Lucia: You can rest assured, the goods...
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Jake:下次用EGB买你的建材
Jake: Next time, I'll use EGB to buy your building materials.
Lucia: 对对对我今天早上还
Lucia: Yes, yes, this morning I...
Lucia: 我今天早上还和领导说
Lucia: This morning I told the boss...
Lucia: 等到他成为了埃隆马斯克的时候
Lucia: When he becomes Elon Musk...
Lucia: 就是一定要记得
Lucia: He must remember...
Jake:哼哼
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 就是给我们这个EOB带带货
Lucia: To promote our EOB.
Lucia: 哈哈哈EOB带带货
Lucia: Hahaha, promote EOB.
Lucia: 哈哈笑死
Lucia: Hahaha, it's hilarious.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
其他人：怎么变异了
Others: How did it mutate?
其他人：你这个是
Others: What is this?
Lucia: 好熟悉
Lucia: So familiar.
其他人：西游记主题曲
Others: Journey to the West theme song
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 嗯是那个丢丢丢吗
Lucia: Hmm, is it the one that goes "didi didi"?
其他人：对
Others: Yes
Lucia: 对嗯他怎么还没有开始丢丢丢
Lucia: Yeah, why hasn't the "didi didi" started yet?
其他人：啊来了
Others: Ah, here it comes
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人：你有没有潮一点的英文名啊
Others: Do you have a trendier English name?
Alice:你意思我的英文名不够潮
Alice: You mean my English name isn't trendy enough?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
其他人：比如
Others: Like what?
Lucia: Alice
Alice:昨天晚上你没看那个片吗
Alice: Didn't you watch that movie last night?
其他人：没有
Others: No
Lucia: 你们昨天晚上看啥了
Lucia: What did you watch last night?
Alice:你放屁
Alice: You're talking nonsense
其他人：有你的名吗
Others: Was your name in it?
Lucia: 就是爱丽丝梦游仙境吗
Lucia: Was it Alice in Wonderland?
Lucia: 你们昨天看的不是就是你拍的那个
Lucia: Didn't you guys watch the one you filmed last night?
其他人：不是就是你拍的那个
Others: Wasn't it the one you filmed?
其他人：那个AI制作的那个短片吗
Others: The one made with AI?
Alice:啊接机的人忘给我拍了
Alice: Ah, the person picking me up forgot to film me
Alice:但是也出现我的名了呀
Alice: But my name still appeared
Alice:你就不细心
Alice: You just weren't paying attention
Alice:你耳朵长的干嘛使的
Alice: What do you even use your ears for?
Lucia: 我当他放那个片是我当时还没上来
Lucia: I thought when he played that movie, I hadn't arrived yet
Lucia: 但是就是就是
Lucia: But it was just
Lucia: 他自我介绍的时候说他叫Alice
Lucia: When he introduced himself, he said his name was Alice
Lucia: 是这个名吗
Lucia: Is that the name?
Lucia: 还是你跟我一样经常换名啊
Lucia: Or do you change names often like me?
Lucia: 其实AA
Lucia: Actually, AA
Alice:没有我就喜欢爱丽丝这个名字哈哈哈
Alice: No, I just like the name Alice, hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:哎哎哎爱丽丝
Alice: Hey hey hey, Alice
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 你这名本来就是a开头的
Lucia: Your name already starts with an "A"
Lucia: 还要再加AAAA
Lucia: And you want to add more "A"s?
Alice:对AA哎哎
Alice: Yes, AA, hey hey
其他人：AAA
Others: AAA
Lucia: 四A级 Alis
Lucia: Four A-levels, Alice
Alice:欢迎进入我的心哈哈哈
Alice: Welcome to my heart, hahaha
Lucia: 我推销点啥呢
Lucia: What should I sell?
Lucia: 我想想
Lucia: Let me think
Lucia: 我把我名字改成我推销的东西
Lucia: I'll change my name to whatever I'm selling
Alice:那刘晨你得卖啥呀
Alice: So, Liu Chen, what should you sell?
其他人：想想
Others: Think about it
Alice:哈哈哈你得卖你的低质
Alice: Hahaha, you should sell your low-quality
Alice:小视频哈哈
Alice: Short videos, haha
其他人：抖家推广
Others: TikTok promotions
Alice:真服了天天拍下来弱智小视频
Alice: I can't believe it, filming silly short videos every day
Alice:还老拉我一起拍
Alice: And always dragging me into it
Alice:对啊我    哈哈哈
Alice: Yeah, I... hahaha
Lucia: 全渠道推广
Lucia: Cross-channel promotions
Lucia: 刘总哈哈哈
Lucia: Boss Liu, hahaha
Alice:给你个心刘婷姐
Alice: Here's a heart for you, Sister Liu Ting
Lucia: 特别专业
Lucia: Very professional
其他人：aaaa爱丽丝
Others: Aaaa, Alice
Alice:装死了在这哈哈哈
Alice: Playing dead over here, hahaha
其他人：是我错觉吗
Others: Is it just me?
其他人：这首歌好像没有歌词啊
Others: This song seems to have no lyrics
Alice:本来就没有啊
Alice: It's supposed to have none
Lucia: 有不是有那个你挑着担
Lucia: Isn't there that "you carry the load"?
Alice:那是另一首
Alice: That's a different song
Lucia: 不是一首啊
Lucia: Not the same one?
Alice:那是路敢问路在何方
Alice: That's "Where is the Road"
Alice:这是云宫训音
Alice: This is "Palace of Clouds"
Lucia: 两个都丢丢丢吗
Lucia: Do both go "do do do"?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Alice:那个没有
Alice: That one doesn't
Alice:搞什么啦
Alice: What are you doing?
其他人：这是AA Alice刚才不是在午休吗
Others: This is AA, Alice was just napping, right?
其他人：然后他是特意把我的拖鞋藏起来了
Others: Then he specifically hid my slippers
Alice:我我我藏你拖鞋干啥
Alice: Why would I hide your slippers?
Alice:你拖鞋老香
Alice: Your slippers smell so good
Alice:是吗
Alice: Really?
其他人：快把我拖鞋藏起来
Others: Quickly, hide my slippers
Lucia: 然后我醒的比较早
Lucia: Then I woke up earlier
Lucia: 然后我先下去把拖鞋穿走他就说啊
Lucia: So I went down first and wore the slippers, then he said
Lucia: 我的拖鞋在哪
Lucia: Where are my slippers?
Alice:哈哈你放屁
Alice: Haha, you're talking nonsense.
Alice:你胡扯
Alice: You're making stuff up.
其他人：明明是你做贼心虚
Others: Clearly, you're feeling guilty.
Alice:谁擦拖鞋谁是狗行吧
Alice: Whoever wipes the slippers is a dog, okay?
Alice:不是我藏的我藏拖鞋干啥
Alice: I didn't hide them, why would I hide slippers?
其他人：谁开拖鞋谁是狗好吧
Others: Whoever takes the slippers is a dog, alright?
Alice:说是开灯不是床头灯
Alice: I said turn on the light, not the bedside lamp.
Alice:那是不小心一个回旋镖扎身上了吗
Alice: Did a boomerang accidentally hit you?
Alice:周六日有空没
Alice: Are you free this weekend?
Alice:咱俩就赏花吧
Alice: Let's go see the flowers.
Alice:不是你凭啥没空呀
Alice: Why are you saying you're not free?
Lucia: 你不是说来找我玩呢吗
Lucia: Didn't you say you were coming to visit me?
Alice:你不是都要走了吗
Alice: Aren't you leaving soon?
Alice:周六日这周
Alice: This weekend, right?
Lucia: 对那你不是说要去西安找我玩吗
Lucia: Yeah, but didn't you say you were coming to Xi'an to see me?
Alice:去西安的旅程还没有定
Alice: The trip to Xi'an isn't planned yet.
Alice:五一我都还没想好回家还是不回家
Alice: I haven't decided if I'm going home for May Day or not.
Alice:我要回家的话我得回家一个多星期
Alice: If I go home, I'd have to stay for over a week.
Alice:不回家的话就不回了
Alice: If I don't go home, then I just won't go.
Alice:看情况吧
Alice: I'll see how it goes.
Lucia: 你们宿舍是几个人 6个
Lucia: How many people are in your dorm? 6?
Alice:6个
Alice: 6.
Alice:你觉得我们宿舍有那么好的条件吗
Alice: Do you think our dorm has such good conditions?
Lucia: 啊你们宿舍是上下铺吗
Lucia: Oh, are your beds bunk beds?
Alice:对啊啊
Alice: Yeah, they are.
Lucia: 你们研究生宿舍居然还上下铺
Lucia: Your graduate dorms still have bunk beds?
Alice:对啊还没本
Alice: Yeah, not as good as undergrad dorms.
Alice:还没本科学校好呢
Alice: Not as good as undergrad dorms.
其他人：嗯那你之前打视频
Others: Hmm, so when you did the video call...
Alice:我给你打的视频啊
Alice: The video call I did with you?
Alice:什么时候给你打视频了
Alice: When did I video call you?
其他人：你显摆你那个茶叶的时候
Others: When you were showing off your tea.
Alice:什么茶叶啊
Alice: What tea?
Alice:等一下
Alice: Wait a second.
Alice:你等我想什么时候给你打个视频
Alice: Let me think when I video called you.
Alice:哎呦啊那是我在我桌子上啊
Alice: Oh, that was on my desk.
其他人：你床上的桌子上
Others: On the desk by your bed.
Alice:不是啊床是床
Alice: No, the bed is the bed.
Alice:桌子是桌子呀
Alice: The desk is the desk.
其他人：你又有床又有桌子
Others: You have both a bed and a desk?
Alice:显示不放桌子只有床
Alice: The display doesn't show a table, only a bed
其他人：等会你们大概什么构造
Others: Wait, what kind of setup do you have?
Alice:是哎
Alice: Yeah
Alice:其实我们那个床能我们那个屋子大小
Alice: Actually, our bed matches the size of our room
Alice:能放6个上床下桌
Alice: It can fit 6 beds with desks underneath
Alice:但是那个构造特别奇怪
Alice: But the setup is really weird
Alice:然后所以就6张单独的桌
Alice: So we just have 6 separate desks
Alice:等于说那个空间就没有利用起来嘛
Alice: Which means the space isn't used efficiently
Alice:然后住的也挤
Alice: And it's cramped to live in
Alice:学习也挤
Alice: And study in
Alice:哎是这样的
Alice: This is how it is at the Communication University of China
Alice:年年换草皮
Alice: They change the turf every year
Alice:年年换树
Alice: And the trees every year
Alice:就不知道给我们宿舍换一下
Alice: But they never think to change our dorms
其他人：咦咦
Others: Oh wow
Alice:咦咦
Alice: Oh wow
Lucia: 他们是不是跟什么建材老板有合作
Lucia: Maybe they have a deal with a construction supplier
Lucia: 然后所以就每年从他那
Lucia: So they buy turf and trees from them every year
Lucia: 哈哈哈每年从他那买草皮和树
Lucia: Hahaha, every year they buy turf and trees from them
Alice:哎谁知道呢
Alice: Who knows
Alice:那我们学校今年新装修的你知道吗
Alice: Did you know our school renovated this year?
Alice:平地起一座桥知道吧
Alice: They built a bridge from scratch, you know?
Alice:跟什么风水大阵一样
Alice: It looks like some kind of Feng Shui setup
Lucia: 我去运作运作给你们
Lucia: I'll work on getting you guys
Lucia: 哈哈提供一些建筑
Lucia: Hahaha, some construction supplies
Alice:真的风水风水阵一样
Alice: It's really like a Feng Shui setup
Alice:就是好好的平路他给上面架个桥啊
Alice: They built a bridge on a perfectly flat road
Alice:又没水又没啥的
Alice: There's no water or anything
Lucia: 我觉得我台词说多了
Lucia: I think I've said too much
Lucia: 到时候AI就以为我真是做建材了
Lucia: The AI might think I'm actually in construction
Alice:没关系哈哈哈
Alice: It's okay, hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈给AI输入一些错误数据
Lucia: Hahaha, input some wrong data for the AI
其他人：哎AI没有办法
Others: AI can't do anything about it
其他人：代替人类的方法找到了
Others: They've found a way to replace humans
Alice: 什么时候把我代替了呀
Alice: When will they replace me?
其他人：你真他妈迫不及待啊
Others: You can't wait, huh?
Alice:对啊我就不用干活了
Alice: Yeah, then I wouldn't have to work
Lucia: 我也不想干活
Lucia: I don't want to work either
Alice:换个歌
Alice: Change the song
Lucia: 我本来是希望AI来代替我干活的
Lucia: I was hoping AI would replace me at work
Lucia: 结果现在AI代替我画画
Lucia: Now AI has replaced me in drawing.
Alice:阿姨好
Alice: Hi, Auntie.
Alice:阿姨现在还不能进去
Alice: Auntie, you can't go in yet.
Lucia: 阿姨您您要稍微等会才能进去
Lucia: Auntie, you need to wait a bit before you can go in.
Alice:嗯那个是
Alice: Hmm, that is...
Lucia: 就是里面
Lucia: It's inside...
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: No worries, no worries.
Lucia: 外面可以
Lucia: Outside is fine.
Lucia: 外面您随便走
Lucia: You can walk freely outside.
Lucia: 就是里面等会才能
Lucia: Just inside, you'll need to wait a bit.
Alice:二楼也可以
Alice: The second floor is okay too.
Alice:但是一楼不能进去
Alice: But you can't go to the first floor.
Alice:不要了
Alice: Nevermind.
Lucia: 咱家能生产这么多垃圾
Lucia: Our family can produce this much trash?
其他人：三四天
Others: Three or four days.
Alice:一星期7天
Alice: A week has 7 days.
Lucia: 7天
Lucia: 7 days.
Alice:然后这个地方已经收了好几次了
Alice: And this place has been cleaned several times.
Alice:咦
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:刘婷刘婷刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting, Liu Ting, Liu Ting.
Alice:哎你什么时候回西安
Alice: Hey, when are you going back to Xi'an?
Lucia: 应该明天吧
Lucia: Probably tomorrow.
Lucia: 不过还没订票
Lucia: But I haven't booked the ticket yet.
Alice:可以这时候订票简单
Alice: You can book the ticket now, it's easy.
Alice:再过几天就不行了
Alice: It won't be as easy in a few days.
Lucia: 对我现在可以看看票
Lucia: Yeah, I can check the tickets now.
Alice:哎这琵琶弹的真牛
Alice: Wow, this pipa playing is amazing.
Lucia: 明天嗯
Lucia: Tomorrow, hmm.
Lucia: 可心你寄不寄东西
Lucia: Kexin, are you sending anything?
Lucia: 明天快递
Lucia: Tomorrow with the courier.
Alice:我没啥想寄的
Alice: I don't have anything to send.
Alice:我打算把我的桌布啥寄成给刘婷
Alice: I'm planning to send my tablecloth and stuff to Liu Ting.
Alice:然后把那个床单被罩跟地毯拿走
Alice: And then take the bed sheets, quilt cover, and carpet with me.
Alice:其他的就不用
Alice: The rest I don't need.
Lucia: 我在想我那个小柜子怎么处理
Lucia: I'm wondering how to handle my small cabinet.
Alice:噔噔噔
Alice: Dun dun dun.
Lucia: 难道我要把它拎到高铁上拎回去吗
Lucia: Do I need to carry it onto the high-speed train?
Alice:太奇怪了
Alice: That's too weird.
Lucia: 太奇怪了
Lucia: Too weird.
Alice:那样很麻烦的
Alice: That would be really troublesome.
Alice:你要是寄回去的话你得把它拆了吧
Alice: If you want to send it back, you have to take it apart, right?
Lucia: 对我就算我哪怕拎着我也得把它拆了
Lucia: Yeah, even if I carry it, I still have to take it apart.
Lucia: 感觉用一次实在是有点浪费
Lucia: Using it just once feels like such a waste.
其他人：扔了浪费
Others: Throwing it away is a waste.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:刘婷你会啥乐器吗
Alice: Liu Ting, do you play any instruments?
其他人：我会b-box
Others: I can beatbox.
Alice:你会退堂鼓哈哈哈
Alice: You can play the "retreat drum," haha.
Lucia: B一个
Lucia: Give us a beat.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
其他人： 箭在弦上也发不了
Others: The arrow is nocked but can't be shot.
Lucia: 哈哈哈箭在弦上也发
Lucia: Haha, the arrow is nocked but can't be shot.
Alice:我回去得把我的那个课赶紧给上完了
Alice: I need to hurry up and finish my class when I get back.
Alice:不上完我怕他过期了
Alice: If I don't finish, I'm afraid it will expire.
Alice:我的古筝课还没上完
Alice: I haven't finished my guzheng class yet.
Alice:去年
Alice: Since last year.
其他人：这么有才艺
Others: So talented.
Alice:被我装到了吧
Alice: Did I impress you?
Alice:确实会没办法
Alice: I really can, can't help it.
其他人：好吧哈哈
Others: Alright, haha.
Alice:好吧
Alice: Okay.
Alice:你要听我弹的吗
Alice: Do you want to hear me play?
Alice:我给你找找
Alice: I'll find it for you.
Lucia: 听
Lucia: Sure.
其他人：来来点来点
Others: Come on, play something.
Alice:啊啊啊
Alice: Ah, ah, ah.
Alice:疼死老娘了
Alice: It hurts so much!
Lucia: 哎呀眼镜没事吧
Lucia: Oh no, are your glasses okay?
Alice:我靠我都快被夹死了
Alice: Damn, I almost got crushed.
Alice:你问眼镜没事吧
Alice: You ask if the glasses are okay?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
其他人：很重要
Others: Very important.
Alice:你没事吧
Alice: Are you okay?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎他怎么还没扫完
Lucia: Why hasn't he finished cleaning yet?
Lucia: 我想进去看看有啥吃的吧
Lucia: I want to go in and see if there's anything to eat.
其他人：已经扫到卧室了客厅没人了
Others: He's already cleaning the bedroom, no one is in the living room.
Lucia: 应该是
Lucia: Probably.
Alice:这是伴奏啊
Alice: This is the accompaniment.
其他人：OK等等等你开始弹的时候你提醒我
Others: OK, wait, let me know when you start playing.
Alice:但是这个进拍子有点错位了
Alice: But this rhythm is a bit off.
Alice:应该从这进
Alice: It should start from here.
Alice:然后我慢了一点
Alice: And then I slowed down a bit.
Jake:充会电没电了
Jake: Charge it, it's out of battery.
Lucia: 那您扫完了吗
Lucia: Have you finished scanning?
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Lucia: 巫巫室水准备好了
Lucia: The Wuwu room water is ready.
Jake:哈哈哈好
Jake: Hahaha, okay.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:这干啥呢
Jake: What's this for?
Alice:他不信我会弹古筝
Alice: He doesn't believe I can play the guzheng.
Alice:我给他放一下我弹的你的作品哦
Alice: I'll play a piece I played for your work.
其他人：自己的作评
Others: Her own critique.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:什么曲子呀
Jake: What piece is it?
Alice:一个流行曲打谱的
Alice: It's a pop song sheet.
Jake:扫扫了一半电没了充会电
Jake: I scanned halfway, then the battery died, so I need to charge it.
Shure: 真是在这干嘛呢
Shure: What's really going on here?
Shure: 怎么突然修身养性了呢
Shure: Why the sudden self-cultivation?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈就是这几天过太苦了哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, it's just been so tough these few days. Hahaha.
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What is this?
Shure: 这是生怒哀乐吗
Shure: Is this life, anger, sorrow, and joy?
Alice:不是这是
Alice: No, this is...
其他人：自己弹了
Others: She played it herself.
其他人： 推广一下古筝大使
Others: Promoting the guzheng ambassador.
Shure: 这谁的古筝
Shure: Whose guzheng is this?
Alice:我的
Alice: Mine.
其他人：深藏不露
Others: Hidden talent.
Lucia: 赏
Lucia: Applaud.
Jake:哈哈哈赏一片
Jake: Hahaha, give a round of applause.
Alice:滚
Alice: Get lost.
Jake:赏易烊千玺一位
Jake: Give an award to Yiyang Qianxi.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Really?
Alice:为啥要赏易烊千玺
Alice: Why give an award to Yiyang Qianxi?
Alice:啊哦
Alice: Ah, oh.
Jake:在这了吗
Jake: Is he here?
Lucia: 比较好赏顺手
Lucia: It's better to give it smoothly.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:还好及时停的1%
Jake: Good thing I stopped at 1% just in time.
Jake:不然白扫了
Jake: Otherwise, it would have been a waste.
Alice:不好听
Alice: Not pleasant to hear.
Alice:听歌吧
Alice: Let's listen to some music.
Alice:嗯嗯
Alice: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:对你俩屋子我扫过了
Jake: I cleaned your two rooms.
Alice:我俩的
Alice: Both of ours?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:你俩屋子我扫过了
Jake: I cleaned your two rooms.
Alice:那是不是可以进去了
Alice: So, can we go in now?
Jake:呃理论上是这么回事
Jake: Uh, theoretically, yes.
Jake:但是可能会补这么
Jake: But we might need to add a few things.
Jake:就是不要太大的变化就行
Jake: Just don't make any big changes.
Lucia: 哎呀妈呀
Lucia: Oh my god.
Lucia: （歌词）i can still hear you
Lucia: (lyrics) I can still hear you.
Lucia: （歌词）make other popping do it all i want
Lucia: (lyrics) make other popping do it all I want.
Lucia: 有有恶犬
Lucia: There are vicious dogs.
Lucia: 可以的吗
Lucia: Is that okay?
Lucia: 呃那有个后面有个垃圾桶
Lucia: Uh, there's a trash can over there.
Lucia: 您能换一下吗
Lucia: Can you change it?
Lucia: 谢谢啊
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 哇啊靠
Lucia: Wow, damn.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 咦呀shit
Lucia: Eww, shit.
Lucia: 好可爱
Lucia: So cute.
Lucia: 这可以收着
Lucia: Can we keep this?
Lucia: 袜子
Lucia: Socks.
其他人： 我想吸那个
Others: I want to vacuum that.
Alice:上面在进行什么活动
Alice: What's happening upstairs?
Lucia: 上面没有什么活动
Lucia: Nothing much upstairs.
Lucia: 所以我在收拾我的房子
Lucia: So I'm tidying up my room.
Lucia: 把可以拆的东西全都取下来
Lucia: I'm taking down everything that can be dismantled.
Jake:不准拆了我们来导数据
Jake: Don't take anything down, we're importing data.
Jake:我把这个眼镜数据导一波嗯
Jake: I'll import this glasses data now, hmm.
Jake:刚刚拆了
Jake: Just took it down.
Jake:拆多少啊
Jake: How much did you take down?
Jake:拆了吗
Jake: Did you take it down?
Lucia: 拆了一些
Lucia: Took some down.
Lucia: 那个还要停着吗
Lucia: Should we stop that?
Lucia: 不是那个还要留着吗
Lucia: Shouldn't we keep that?
Jake:留着留着
Jake: Keep it, keep it.
Lucia: 等一下我手机在上面
Lucia: Wait a sec, my phone's up there.
Jake:刚刚露西亚戴着眼镜拆就很好
Jake: Just now, Lucia was wearing glasses and unpacking really well.
Jake:但是现在要导一波数据
Jake: But now we need to import some data.
其他人：购物中心从未迷路
Others: Never get lost in a shopping mall.
其他人：这不是要我的命吗
Others: Isn't this gonna kill me?
其他人：对呀
Others: Yeah.
其他人：无所谓反正
Others: Doesn't matter anyway.
Alice:你这个不太好哦
Alice: This isn't very good, you know.
Jake:你要是坑我
Jake: If you screw me over...
其他人：你什么意思
Others: What do you mean?
其他人：你想跟我先下solo是吗
Others: You want to solo me first, huh?
Alice:我线下直接杀你好吗
Alice: I'll kill you offline, okay?
Alice:你坑我我啪一巴掌我就过去
Alice: If you screw me over, I'll slap you right away.